[Musique]
pilonné par l'armée russe depuis
plusieurs semaines l'usiné opstal est le
symbole de la résistance ukrainienne à
marioupol après les évacuations de
civils il ne reste qu'un groupe de
soldats encerclés par les troupes russes
qui cherche à faire sauter le dernier
verrou de cette ville stratégique
mario paul et viser dès le début de
l'invasion la ville est un point clé
pour les russes qui souhaite prendre le
contrôle total sur la mer d'azov pour
l'obtenir moscou multiplie les fera le 9
mars l'ukraine et l'union européenne
dénonce un premier crime de guerre
lorsqu'une maternité bombardé quelques
jours plus tard c'est le théâtre de la
ville qui est pulvérisée alors qu'ils
abritent près d'un millier de civils
si vous donc ça je les nie
bonjour à tous le cas du
site
machine à 16 h au collège conrad
après une première phase de
bombardements la cité portuaire est
assiégée par les russes kiev rejette un
premier ultimatum du kremlin qui demande
la capitulation totale de la ville
l'armée ukrainienne se prépare alors à
une ultime bataille finalement le 21
avril vladimir poutine revendique la
victoire à marioupol et ordonne
d'assiéger le site des obstacles c'est
vrai qu'elle retire
après deux mois de bombardements
marioupol est presque complètement
détruite selon les autorités
ukrainiennes début avril deux cent
cinquante mille personnes avaient déjà
quitté la ville